[BIRDS CHIRPING AND SCHOOL BELL
RINGING]
Welcome to the first section
of RU204, Managing JSON
Data in Redis.
In the next four units,
you'll learn the following,
the rationale for
using the Redis JSON
module over the core
Redis offering, how
to store JSON documents
in Redis with Redis JSON,
how to retrieve subdocuments
and specific values
within documents, how to
update existing documents
and add new
subdocuments and values.
Each unit will have a
hands-on exercise designed
to explore the topics covered
and solidify your Redis JSON
skills.
Since the goal of this
section is to familiarize you
with Redis JSON,
the exercises will
be based on entering commands
into the Command Line Interface
to demonstrate common actions
performed on JSON documents.